All right. Welcome to the DDPS seminar everyone. Before we introduce our invited speaker, let's go over some rules as usual. First of all, please mute yourself during the talk. If you have immediate questions, you're welcome to unmute and ask. Otherwise, please use the chat room to post your questions so that we can address them in the q&a session at the end. Second, today's seminar is open to external audience. So no classified discussion is allowed annually, the talk will be recorded and uploaded to our YouTube channel. So now let me introduce our speaker. It is an honor to your host, Alvaro
Coutinho, who is a professor in civil engineering and the CO coordinator of the interdisciplinary area of computational engineering and science at COPPE The Alberto Luiz Coimbra Institute for Graduate Studies and Research in Engineering in the Federal University of Rio de Janeiro in Brazil. He got his doctoral degree in the same school in 1987. He is a recipient of an IBM faculty Partnership Award in 2001. The JT is the audit and faculty fellowship at UT Austin in 2004. The Giulio Massarani Academic award at COPPE in 2007 and the International Association of competition mechanics Fellow award in 2012. Professor Coutinho has organized national and international conferences, training workshops and short courses serving in scientific committees of many conferences, including the Supercomputing Conference design conference on parallel processing file MS in flow clubrooms, the US National Congress on competition mechanics and a road Congress on computational mechanics. He serves on the executive committee of the International Association of the computational mechanics and in the Brazilian association for computational methods in engineering. He is a member of the editorial board of international journal of numerical methods in engineering and computational methods in applied mechanics and engineering. And on the effort advisory board of the International Journal of numerical methods and fluids, he coordinate over 80 industrial projects, directed further three PhD thesis and 47, Master of Science dissertations. He is author of 136 peer reviewed journal papers and over 450 conference papers. He was the PI of the Brasilia project HPC for E high performance computing for energy from 2017 2000 to 2020. He is currently the PI of the informatics network of in artificial intelligence for renewable energy and climate change, supported by the real the general state agency for research. Today, he will talk about enhancing data driven workflows for complex simulations, please enjoy the wonderful talk. Now without further ado, let me hand it over to everyone. Okay, thanks, Tony. For the long introduction, you could really shorten just by say I still play beach volleyball. Okay. Well, it's a pleasure to be here today. And well, you'll see my screen and I'm glad to share with you our view on how to enhance data driven workflow for complex simulations. The agenda for today is, well, we'll do a quick review on the simulation workflow. Then we're going to talk about your see how Institute of Israel diseases fits within and how we do computational steering. And then the first first question we're going to address in this talk as have snapshot based data driven computations fit within this simulation workflow within stata visualization, then we're going to see a lot of case studies using basically a dynamic mode decomposition. Okay. So there's a lot of questions, we'll see. First, we're gonna ask ourselves, what would happen if it compressed the snapshots? What we do if the snapshots are not in the same space, for instance, coming from Adaptive mesh refinement and cortical computations? And then I'm going to discuss how can we makes the Institute of visualization workflow, what is streaming DMD? Is it good for anything and then I let's, let's discuss this. And in the end, if I have time, I will address a particular more theoretical issue on the end, should we do it couple or uncouple and of course So we will open for a q&a session in the end. All right. Here Here you see the basically a simulation workflow. It starts with some pre processing various select parameters, like at an ECL time step, the time interval, set tolerance, and pick up the solvers. And set up in all the setup for the adaptive mesh refinement in courses, simulation, etc, then stop time stepping. So while you're not reach your timing, maximum time interval, your assembly and sold nonlinear equations, your adaptive mesh and the time step, you're updating your solution. And then if, if it's time to save data on this, when required, update for time step and move on. In the end, you have a lot of data in the disk, your post processing, you do the post process, basically visualize the data and extract relevant quantities of interest. Well Is that a assembly in solving linear linear equations by some Newton like method is where you will spend most of your computer time. Innovate Step B. Guarantees accuracy in in space and time. And step D is where you do IO to persistent storage. And the right you'll see some solutions, you know, some simulations coming from our group. Let's see that beautiful one here on the top is a solution of a non local phase field model with Phoenix. And on the right you can see a timestamp via for order of magnitude adaptive time step Brian for you know several orders of magnitude and below the simulation for a droplet impact using live mesh with adaptive mesh refinement and coursing. And you can see you know, that showing the mesh adaptivity. Well, many years ago, this basically workflow that still is still valid. In this paper here in supercomputer in 2010, they realized that the optimal complexity of this workflow is order of n to the power four over three or n is your total number of your unknowns is easy to realize. Now let's think that you have n over three acute let's say within over three unknowns in each of the parties and directions and you do a implicit time step with a number of time steps of order of n if you get everything together you'll get this n to the power of four three is optimal in there is only optimal if you solve your linearized equations without an algorithm it is linear scale is linearly on time which is hardly to achieve more or less we what we see here is the only way to improve this is diminishing the number of points in space and time okay. But there remains the IO in persistent storage and digitalization in getting insight from your computations alright. So, how does this workflow becomes been put in place in situ visualization, utilization results of running simulations instead of users this is basically do the visualization without the need to copy data to a storage device. Of course, it reduces the amount of data and adds to reducing traffic IO and volume. And you can think that you can access more data. For instance, if you are writing to the disk, at this interval, when doing signal processing, you can do can do more intervals. More than that, people realize that we can, we can do in real time the simulation exploration and the steering. Of course, it reduces lattice latency to the first result and avoid large scale post processing. So the traditional workflow we have the simulator code, dump everything to the disk and do the visualization later. With this. Now we write an adapter for this powerful catalyst which is our our choice for instant visualization infrastructure is not the only one. And you can then produce you Using some scripts, visualization in runtime, new applications you see in this yellow box in the bottle are two new applications are from the group coming from the Kansas and Colorado border that are so cool. They do, you know, they, they go beyond an enabling you to change your let's say, change your your, your domain during the simulations using using this in SQL tools. And also merge couple in this is in situ, which simulation workflow and the machine learning workflow. They're so cool, I really appreciate that so much. And I encourage you to read this. So how it works basically in more detail. The same the workflow with instead of visualization and is theory. Here, we build that on top of lib mesh, you set up the adaptive mesh refinement of courses set up, start the simulation setup, and then you start looping time loop. You know, as a couple months physics solver, you do the fluid solver, you do the transfer equation, here we are. This was specialized for sediment transport, you're gonna see the application in a moment. And do we need an adaptive mesh refinement, we do the writer and then we move to the catalyst adapter, call that catalyst adapter, and those tracks from the python script and generating PNG files for ViSalus visual visualization in certain what we also do with this tool called the F analyzer. The details are in this yellow box in the in below in the slide is that we also gather other data that allows us to interact with a lot of parameters. And during the simulation at the runtime, we we annotated some data in the database and then we query this database if needed and changing everything in the runtime more or less, we can see this box here that we are annotated Nalina tolerances, time steps in and some data needed for controlling adaptive mesh refinement and of course, inland mesh. Alright, how it works, okay, this is a simulation sediment ran up and channel this is a big channel. And this is you know, visualization generated in situ is a highly turbulent flow with several can see Reynolds number here is 5000. And is interesting that we have some experimental data. And the black curve corresponding to the adaptive mesh refinement and coursing simulation that you can see on the right for a longer time and see in this detail here is adaptive mesh for this configuration. So how competition is steering walks. Right. So we are some user interacting with the code series with when it's running. And then that certain point at that time step, the user decide that. Let's relax some tolerances here and see what happens. And then he can do it in runtime, and changing this tolerances and also adapt more adaptive mesh refinement tolerances, and see if there's okay. And the simulation progresses. Well, the air in what we see here is a huge saving in computer time. And we can control this is runtime, I mean essence, everything is annotated in the database that we're aware we can query and interact with many parameters in runtime. So this is basically a simulation workflow, where instead of utilization and steering, all this immediate image that you've seen, they have been produced by the Institute of visualization capabilities. Right. So now can with the data driven registered order model, as I said before, I will restrain myself to talk about DMD. But if I'm, if I succeed in my presentation, you're gonna see that several of those more computational computer science thinks can be applied to other ways of building reduced order models. Well, DMV needs observation for a nonlinear problem at hand. And this observation often comes from snapshots of a large parallel simulation with a workflow just like the one we have discussed. Snapshots are written to disk, due to the gap between computing and IO spin, as Snapchat generation can become a bottleneck, particularly for large simulation DMD as any several other reducer otter models, builds the reducer of a model, of course, from a single value decomposition of the snapshot matrix. So we ask ourselves, and you can see, then in the yellow box here, the paper that we will be building one of the paper we're going to be building my talk today, we ask ourselves those good things in red here. What happens if we compress the snapshots to the minute IO. And also, what happens when we merge DMD with the simulation workflow with incentivization and steering? Those are the two things we will address in a minute, the two next things I will address in this talk. Okay, so this picture here is to try to give you an idea how this workflow will be merged, we have the offline phase in HPC machine, this is a simulation with a live mesh and a finite element simulation. And then we have a two branches, this tender branch where you dump everything to the disk, but now with maybe lossless and lossy data compression, using one I will come back to this one using one floating point compressor. And then we have a compressor snapshot that has to be decompressed. To be so condemned, it can walk. And the other hand, you have here the institutionalization. In our framework and running together, we are the simulation that you generate a PNG files. And this PNG files generated at runtime is a feat affair to the incremental DMD and can then you can do the online phase in IR, rock station or laptop. So of course, I'm in this full artist simulation, take ours. And of course, the name, the reconstruction takes seconds, everybody knows that. But most of the tools we're going to be using here comes from the exascale computing project from the doe. And that particular you can find this in the alpine CFP, which is one of the projects. So, we're going to have we basically are going to discuss here, what's gonna happen if we do data compression, and how we merge the instead of visualization with incremental DMD with gun as we're gonna see, we blurry, mix it up, somehow, the offline and online phase of this, there's four of the DMD workflow. Okay, just to make a point. This is the vanilla the MDR grid, there's axiom Daragh written, you're not in lib Ron, you have this is just to make a point that, we're always going to be using a randomizer. That's in SVD. And incremental SVD. Okay. But one of the things that we have to take care of is, when you do large scale simulation, there is not shots comes from those parallel computations. They are distributed in the file system. As you can see, here, this is a nice picture, show you the meters partition for our 16 processor for you know, some of the analysis we did in for CFD many years ago, is a Lazada class submarine mesh. We use this mesh for many, for many, you know, CFD competitions in the past, but my point here is that the special care should be given to the subdomain interface data, you're there to arrange does not check the snapshots. Why is that? So? Because partition for computing SVD, which is basically a dense matrix is not exactly the same. partition that when you do, I mean, there's snapshots that come in download to disk from a parallel simulation. Okay, so we have to take care of this. Right. Now, let's get back to spend a bit of time doing talking about compressing floating point numbers. Well, several state of the art in lossy and lossless scientific data compressor have been evaluated. Recently since the desirable paper here, called SDR bench is bench they propose a benchmark for scientific data reduction for lossy compressors. There's in this paper it can find many and we selected zfp which is one that operators on a three dimensional array. by partitioning this array into blocks of four to the power devalues. Each blocks is compressing the complex entirely independently from all other blocks. Well, when you use zfp, you can control the blocks quality and compressive size by modifying four parameters, I will not go into the details of this parameters. But at a high level zfp provides five predefined compression modes that affect these parameters, expert fixed rates, fixed procedure and fixer curious and reversible. The first four modes is a lower high compressor razor with controllable loss of accuracy. And the wildly last one performs loss of s contraction. Why is the f3 we use the FB? Well, because there is a strong mathematical background, there's a paper discussing error analysis for the FB that you can see here in this yellow box has been published in the same genre for scientific computing a few years ago. And that's why we adopted CFP. So, in more than that, we adopt the sticks that are tourismo that given a tolerance that we select Set minutes per meter to this expression floor flock to the tolerance which means in practice that for incompressible floating point F in a reconstructive valid G the absolute difference of f and g is at most two to the power Min X. Also what is interesting is now zfp is available as for compression decompression floating points on AGF five files format using this plugin here. So it's easy to use. Right? Well, let's see what's going to happens. I come back to this problem that we are analyzing a few years ago is a particle driven graph the flow and the lock is change. Here you have water with sediment here's clean water is basically a couple incompressible navier stokes equation with sediment transport at Grashof pentyl, Paris six summit number one, which means the flow is driven by turbulence at well, you can get the details for the day for the initial condition and boundary conditions in our paper. But I'm just making a point here that at the bottom, you have this boundary condition for sediment concentration, which means that sediments are allowed to live the domain we assume the Boussinesq hypothesis valid particular particles have a heavy in the heavy fluid have a negligible inertia and much more more smaller than the scales balancing just for the mouse motion. We settled setting the last 2.2 Is the trial inner hexahedral mesh mesh with great grid spacing point 035. We're using the residual base variation multiscale finite element formulation for the fluid and streamline upwind Petrov Galerkin finite element formulation for sediment transport, and we record 1000 snapshots. The full word a model is a live mesh parallel simulation, we spend roughly 80% of the time when the solvers are less than point 1% for output writing, half point percent of total time for paravur catalysts and 18% for the remainder of the task. And we use measure EO for mapping DMD approximation and modes to the original notes, not of coordinates. This is a snapshot of the simulation, but you can see the formation of the Kelvin Helmholtz billows. Okay. Yeah, so snapshot complex on this table here. So the storage requirement for the quantities of interest in compression rates for the simulations. You can see for the raw data for the zfp with lossless compression, and ZF we'll fix the Rikyu was for two tolerances one more tight and on more relaxing and and we are recording we were storing the raw the three velocity components UV w the pressure the sediment concentration and sediment deposition, you see that as far as some of those variables, we achieve high rates of compression, you know, the sediment concentration and the deposition in they're all compatible with the people recorded in the benchmark I mentioned before. So, this is more or less what people have seen in those datasets. What remains to be seen now is when we do this, of course, we're gonna save a lot of disk, but how this will influence DMD and reconstructions. Okay. So, we do the reconstruction, this plot here in your left show you the big sign noise ratio, which is a measure of how good are your compressors in blue zfp lossless PS and are in decibels around more than 100 which is very good zfp with accuracy a fixer creates the tendon power minus six is over 75 With considering Excellent. And for, you know, keeping three, keep in three or four digits is not that good, but is acceptable. And the right you see the influence of compression on the symbol of ballots, well, the dashed line represents, you know, the base of the 250 similar values that are going to be selected for the DMD reconstruction, we see a deviation, similar values for when we do you know, when we are when we do a very aggressive, lossy compression, and but the single the singular values agree with it, you see, lossless and no compression are on top of each other, and we do a less aggressive, we have a very good match until let's say 350. So we're gonna do, we're gonna see what happens when we do with reconstruction with 250 You know, a single foot with the bases built with 250 melts, or Okay, oops, all right. But before that, let's see what happens with the DMD Eigen value analysis for the loss compression for 10 minus six, you see that all the apparently all the Eigen values are okay, we have some small discrepancies, and we when we do zoom in in this box, but however, for the more aggressive compression, we see more discrepancy in the Eigen values and of course, we will, it will affect the empty reconstructions. So, in this table here, you see the forbade news nor relative error between the approximate and unreasonable snapshots for this problem, consider a basis of 250 you see the Frobenius norm, okay, more or less, when we do no compression or lossless compression or this 10 to the minus six security, they're more or less of the same order, but they are twice as big, when we do a more more aggressive compression. This picture on right see, you can see the absolute error between the DMD reconstruction with a basis of 250 50. With a basis using 250 eigenvector from the lossy compressing data with 10 to power six minus six compression and there is no snapshot for segment that kind of situation at this time. So you see very is more absolute error, but this is not enough. Let's see more measure other measures. In the graph in your left you'll see the relative error in time measured as the difference between the reconstructed solution and the end solution. You see them the norms and see that this zero is very, you know, when you do no compression, in in in orange lossless compression you In green lossy with the 10 to the minus $6. And the more aggressive compression, we see a very good error. The lossy and lossless are more or less on top of each other until that time and there are certain different diversions afterwards words, and but it overrode their errors is still low below them to the minus two. And right you see the time history of the relative seven mass error for all cases they are very good. And when you do very aggressive, lossy compression decompression, you see that there are some oscillations, but overall the mess is very well reconstructs. Finally, well a minute people who do this simulations, there are some quantities of interest global conflicts of interest that they always look. One is the front position over time. And for this, which is basically how you compute how rare is the front over time, you can see there's a very good match, no matter of what you do, using raw data, for the for the model raw data from the simulation, and all the compressor compressing all the snapshots, you see, for this global constant interest, you're on top. And also from the sediment mess time history, that's, you see the same thing. So I mean, it appears that compressing snapshots by using a some with keeping some accuracy, good balance between you know how much you're gonna compress? And decompress is is a good idea, by the way that the decompress time for the MD is negligible. Okay. All right. So, let's see, what happens when we have snapshots coming for an adaptive mesh refinement and coursing. Well, when when you do adaptive mesh refinement course simulations, the meshes we have they have of course, a different number of nodes and numbering in order coordinates and it can also lead to different mesh topologies instructors for instance, this is a CR three levels of refinement and then you see you know, I mean this matters of course, they don't live in the same space and you can have something like this a hanging node with a constraint and by the neighbors or you can have situation like this nashwan and messages to that they have they have the same number of degrees of freedom, but different topologies we circumvent this issue by considering alto projection of the numerical simulation results for different meshes into a reference target mesh. So, there are some issues here okay. The choice of a proper method to successfully project functions in different finite element space is not a trivial task in particular, because conservation may not be satisfied, if you go to the literature there, there are several walks in dressing this issue. However, we have to bear in mind here that mess projects are for us in to build you know, a dam these snapshots, they are course as a post processing phase after computing the adaptive mesh refinement cost solution. Therefore, it cannot lead to cumulative errors. So projection is not doesn't accumulate error. There is another issue here is how much the snapshots will retain from the regional the regional accuracy of this adaptive mesh. So, what we found out that we need to choose a reference target meshes target mesh with a characteristic length equivalent with the system in adaptive meshes in order to avoid major accuracy losses. So let's see how it works. That solution or the dollar mesh be given by the suspension satisfying this LT projection here in the proper space. And of course l two is defined by the target mesh and in temporal and here you sub project is the optimal Carolan interpret in this L two nor from this space. So, we compute the L two projection is orthogonal projectors is defined in the following linear system. And you this isn't going to solve this for your project, where m is a standard mass matrix for any finite element code in B is a projection matrix. Well, we've proved the theorem in this paper down here is that if every degree of freedom of the reasonable mesh is also a degree of freedom of the resin F reference mesh, then the matrix B is full rank, right, which is very tough to requirements of the math in practice. But we find out that having a reference mesh representing the fine scale is enough for practical purposes. So, this algorithm is a snapshot projection we work like this have an input the finite element solution, considering adaptive mesh refinement of courses in the output data projects and solutions. So for each observation time step, you'll apply them to projection and stack the result in snapshot maintenance or output the projected solution to this compressor or not compressor doesn't matter. On the right, you can see here's as you know, I'm going to is a simple exercise, we project the solution and this is adaptive mesh, and this is infinity norm is one when you use this mesh with represented finest scalar. Here, the projection is very good. Or if we project in a totally unstructured mesh more or less keeping the same scale we have also a very good a very good error. Right. So let's check out how it works in practice. Let's examine right now, the problem of a 3d Rising bubble which basically a capo navier stokes equation, sorry, just one second is a couple navier stokes equations with a convected level set where we consider surface tension with a continuous surface model. The details are in the paper in this yellow box here. This is the initial condition and no slip boundary condition apply to all boundaries. The computation domain is this box here we're going to have grid size. In this interval, there'll be 240 time steps. This is a timestamp the bubble radio the inside bubble position in the properties and we consider gravity like this. So, first thing is how this idea of looking at projected meshes works. We can see here this plots the adaptive mesh solution, the projection for this time step and of course mesh in intermediate mesh in a fine mesh projection. And in the table here, you can see how costly is the projection you'll see well for fine mesh as the projected cost is negligible and is its projection like this out to projection is available on this either is not as part of a landmass is part of Phenix. So projection is not an issue. The issue here is how the solution becomes menu really do take a look on the solution quality in this project and matches. So, you'll see some quantities of interest for this problems is the volume of the bubble, the sphericity the rise velocity and the center of mass for the you know for the simulation with adaptive mesh, and for Matt and the output in the quote with the course intermediate and then find projects and of course the course from the project the solution project and the course match is good for nothing, but for the intermediate mesh and the find one there you know this quantities are okay, which gives us a good indication that projectile projectile can give you a snapshot in the same base in the same space. So we proceed to do the MD reconstruction with the projected meshes here is basically the relative error for the reconstructions and we see his relative error here. And this is the training and then afterwards training, you see the trainer is the arrow increases a bit, but we have a win in all this at the end are good. And for the course, mesh is not that good. But you can see in this two slides here, that the bubble shape at that, for the sign during the sign reconstruction, which is the end here of the training and for the prediction, within the last step is more or less, okay, and we can see some really oxalates are for the coarse mesh. And, of course, in this table here is see for several ranks the MD reconstructions, and then they see the relative error. Of course, if you increase the rank of reconstructions, the error diminishes. But and you have, you see a, you know, astonishing a very a very, very, very nice speedups. So, it seems to be a good idea to, to have all these snapshots in the same space by projecting the solutions. So let's see how the MD performs for the quantities of interests. Again, I see volume sphericity, the rise velocity and center of mass. And I believe this is for using the record, I'm sorry, for using the reconstruction with 60 vectors. And you see again, reconstruct the MD reconstruction with a coarse mesh is good for nothing, but for the or for defining an intermediate projection. They are value, I mean, you can do it without any problem. Okay. So let's now see is the if how this idea of mesh projection of having all the snapshots in the same space walks when we merge this with, with data compression. So by using only the final protected mesh, here is the time share is now in the offline file phase is 90%. For solvers, less than 1% of the time for output writing 1% for power of your catalyst 3.3% for the bubble position projection to reference mesh, and 80% for reminder, workflow components, but including all the stuff you need for adaptive mesh refinement, in coursing process inland mesh for this specific problem. And you can see here you see a view of the for the time 2.25 The adaptive mesh match with the velocity price in the velocity plots and the corresponding projection of the level set or the bubbles position at the final mesh. Note here that we compress both the level set field on adaptive mesh and the level set field on the projected mesh. The projected mesh contain more nodes and elements and given that it's the same Metro snapshots, of course, it enabled the use of DMD all the other fields are stored in their original and depth meshes. So here again, we see the table we can see the three velocity components and then compress it in the compression rates, the pressure the the level set of this in this in adaptive mesh, and the Lego set in a protected mesh that will be used for the DMD reconstructions, you'll see that we achieved some less, we can discuss it later, why we achieve less than in the other case, but still good compression rates. Okay. And again, now we do the same thing. This is the big to sign noise ratio. And we see that for zfp and lossless compression and the same accuracy level for zfp compression. Here we don't see you know, more or less the the lossless and zfp. We're curious 10 to minus six is more or less on top of each other and the quality of the aggressive, more aggressive data compression is not that not that, you know, they still have a good quality this is somehow reflected manual look at the singular values for a basis of 20. Similar values, we, we have exceeded all the singular values. And I'm going to do the reconstructions of with 20 vectors, but they're all more or less on top of each other. And if we look at the Frobenius norm, relative norm between the approximate and original snapshot for a basis with 20 vectors, we see there are more or less the same order of magnitude. And again, the DMD Eigen values, if you look at them, the raw data the last less and the to compress it in the compressor with different different tolerance, they're all on top of each other more or less reflecting what we see in the signal of similar values. Okay. So, this is the relative on the left relative error in time for the reconstruction between the vectors, we see that that's okay is relative error and time is bounded then minus two and the timing history of the bubble mess which is which is very, very similar with the what began what got with no compression at all. Right. So, so far, we have been, you know, seen the effects of data compression and how to handle snapshots with different coming from in when they live in different spaces. We do it by compression. And now we're going to see what we do when we merge DMD with in situ visualization. Alright, some water and do faster here. We see, well, do we have seen the integration between live mesh and parallel catalysts and this is provided by adapter, which is implemented when on one of the catalysts API's more or less we couple live mesh with Parvo catalysts and we produce a PNG files that will feed streaming the DMD. The adapter invokes a Python script, which is supported for the power of your user interface. And the adapter involves this processes initialize, go process and finalize, which are methods to invoke pipelines defined in this Python scripts. The data structure for from the simulation code is assessed in memory I mean, in situ, and they are mapping into adapter using the API for purview catalysts, and catalyst using VT gate data model to perform the data structure mapping. The use of this simple we output PNG file every X time steps, and the right right data ever KX timestamps with K is much more than one and PNG file files are ingested into the streaming TM the algorithm which is on the right I'm not going to do is I'm just saying it's very similar to the incremental SVD of finding labor on however, it's tailored for receiving PNG images. We use this Python package open CV for handle image and psychic image for computing metrics. And the images are converted to black and white before processing and pixels are Heather has no failures in the snapshot matrix. This is to make things simpler. Alright. So what we do the industry medium the underlying block is changing computation. We use powerful catalysts to generate image images for us at the midplane of the all of the lock exchange problem. PNG files have only this amount of pixel width accounts for 153 megabytes we store all our 1000 image we we store for every time step and this is the reconstructed for basically 250 DMD modes k out visually there's no difference between any of this for the model image that the Institute of visualization image produced with online with the purview with the Florida model data and the reconstruction with the purview, same image with DMD reconstructions, however, have to bear in mind that assessing accuracy image needs more different metrics. Why we use this structural similarity index which is computed like This is very standard, I just would like to point out that if this is the original image, and this is to compressor, the compressor, the image, the PNG, maybe you have, you know, the same ms II. But this metric tells you that this, the image on the right is much better than the middle image. So when we handle everything as images, they're better use this metrics in order to assess quality, together with our standard metal more mathematical error analysis. So for like a standard problem, what we, what we get when using the streaming DMD, this mark here is, is the mark that we have 250 snapshots and, oh, they have construction keeps going with this, there's 250 snapshots or PNG files coming in. And you see this metrics, as close to one is means that Jamin images are very good. And you see by the scale of that says is true. The DMD reconstructed images are very good. And that is also reflected in Frobenius norm in time, and also in the relative error. They always tell us that the reconstruction the with this, using the images, producing the vibrancy to visualization, they're, you know, they're the reconstructions are very good. What we got when we do the same thing, the 3d Rising bubble problem, well, now we generate black and white images at the bubble midplane PNG files have only this. So, we have a three megabytes for storing old 240 image and we do reconstruction with Rs 60 and C, you see the the power of your catalyst image, the name the reconstruction and so on. We see here in the end, after the training does mean the prediction phase that DMD does not do a good job in the reconstruction but is more or less, we knew that when we when we observe the reconstruction, the bubble perhaps, is because the boundary conditions we we apply here isn't is a no slip boundary condition. And this is reflected in. In, in, in the other metrics. This is the similarity struggle similarity index for the record tracks and match images from the bubble shape is still good. And we see a degradation here in the end. Again, this is a you know, when you start to have the 16 standard reconstruction, the Frobenius norm is not that good and but still tolerable. And the error is growing, as we saw before, but it's still acceptable. Okay, and we have five minutes. Should I continue or stop here and go to the q&a? I can go very quickly on this. Basically, there's what do you think, Tony? Yeah, I think it's up to you. We are pretty flexible in the schedule, okay. I mean, I will jump to this because it's more theoretical work. Suppose we have a PD system that we have this vector here and this is a kind of multi compartmental system and isn't only an operator that defines the interaction between an INFJ compartments. Of course, this place is equipped with B C's in initial condition for each compartment and depending on the type of the patient we can use, you know, the Larkin Petrov Galerkin, a variation load scale for spatial discretization. The question here is what we do within with MD reconstruction, it is the will freedom or each compartment separately or stack of them like this and do the DMD for the copying approach. Of course, this will demand more memory. But of course, in the reconstruction follow this fraction, but see which one is is better. Right. In this paper below. We have a mathematical analysis. And we have three we have proved three theorems. First one is for a compartmental dynamic systems such that we have this conservation, the exact same the reconstruction utility here also, you know is conservative. The second theorem says that for problems with some subset of a compartment satisfies the hypothesis of theorem want it to remain theorem one also holds for the DMD reconstruction in this subset. The third theorem says that for a compartmental problem with satisfy the hypothesis of theorem one, we have additionally, that this is, you know, this condition here that the compartments are, are positive or zero and the MD reconstructions are also this positive or zero at all positions in time, then we have the L one arrow is bounded for all type some remarks on this theorems, there is no negativity hypothesis on your tilde 14 Three, it's hard to say that this holds in general, and this quantities be may become negative. But what we've seen practice that this assumption remains satisfied for many problems, at least, for a model a period of time after the end of the training periods. In such a regime to train, we may suspect that there are bound given by two and three to help preventing the blow up the era. Moreover, if one was to perform them the ornamented variable space, let's say we have one we used to this two compartment and unknown in a combination of those. We would suspect that this conservation will hold in the DNA reconstruction despite the presence of the nonlinear variable. The mathematical details is already paper, I will skip this, but let's see how it works. This is a system if we actually diffuser equations, which basically is a special temporal domain. suggestible In fact, it's recovered and this is a population for simulating spreading of disease. So, as I said before, as a standard for the susceptible compartment II for infected are for the cover, and then the for disease, the sum the sum of all compartment with the Center of Disease population is represented by the population, the total number of leading people, the better as the transmission rate gammas are the symptom symptom African recovery rates, delta is the mortality rate. And here is that our distribution tensors of the different population groups, and the signal incorporated the lag effect presenting between the time of faction in developed symptoms, and the model six, you know, and in six to model the delay of seven in practice, when new restriction of other measures are introduced in the details of the model is in the paper in the yellow box in below in the slide. Alright, the model walks. This is in in in pink, you see the symbol in this the number of the season population against what was measured in state of Georgia in the US. And we observe an accent that women for the total population for Georgia for this model, and this is the evolution of the impacted infected compartment i for the GA simulation of different phases of the epidemic. They weren't they one month, four months, and they weren't 150. Of course, the outbreak is more was more severe around the Atlanta area, but we have other hotspots as well. Well how DVD performs on this. Well, we're gonna see that the variation of the you know, the, the mass has to be conservative. And we see that if we do the MD reconstruction in a couple uncoupled way. We see we don't see any conservation. But however, if we do the request DMD reconstruction with a couple way, we see a very good conservation even beyond the training periods. And this is the infected compartment, you know, five days after the end of the training periods, and we have a very good agreement between the four model and then the request functional for the couple using the couple way of doing this okay in this is the error analysis and for the GA simulation This is the how we compute the error and for the different compartment is susceptible infected recovered indices, we see that a couple of them the reconstruction fail for several compartment giving an a set of results in contrast, the couple DMD formulation you know, reconstructed the dynamics even after training and provides reasonable stipulation for three week inter interval which is very good for the problems of you know, epidemic precision and it more or less confirms what the mathematic mathematical analysis have you know, predicted for us. So, final remarks and discussion to end and then and finally go to the q&a some more water before I started my final remarks Okay, we have seen that lossy compression diminish the snapshot persistent storage requirements and contributors to decrease IO Diem the approximations used to decompress the data may lose accuracy, depending on the singular value stress hold. If lost data compression changes the singular values before the educational level. Jim the eigenvalues may tend to and I'm gonna SPECT not a good reconstruction. We have observed that decompressing the snapshot does not increase computational effort during the in the approximation. One thing I it's I'm pretty sure data compression is here to stay you guys in the labs are putting in a lot of effort on doing this in compressing compressing scientific data set. So is there in please use it there are other options in XFP that remains to be explored. I'm not claiming that we did the best job we just said okay. Look data compression here is good, but we have to you know, do more computations in Splore more now, of course, there are other scientists data compression work taking a look like SZ M God plus etc. And one thing that is important for you guys in the liberal community is I believe that any method based on snapshot can benefit from data compression is more or less obvious this thing but we I never see many people use scientific floating point compression in in in this method and we could SPECT more savings for our Lupron computations. You see, when you do of course, if you do parametric parametric studies that were generated much more data. Well, when you do more compression, you do more more saving. So, you know, I mean, by compromise using floating point in compressions for parametric studies can expect much more savings. Again, I mean, using image data for DMD approximation presents accurate results considering the presented metrics, with notable stars reduction with promoting simple data transfer. Another thing is, projections of fix a match could not the best could not be the best way of dealing dealing with a snapshot when in different spaces. But it's simple. Why? While l two projectors is embedded in many existing codes, open source codes like live mesh Phenix and I believe in many of the simulation codes available that do we we have this projection already implemented. Our experience shows that the hint is if possible, select the fifth fixed mesh containing approximately the smaller scales obtaining in your adaptive mesh refinement of course and solution. Well, I mean, institutionalisation turns the offline in online phases blurry. They are somehow have mixed it together. If it's possible to generate incentivization image, target to the problem is q you cue points of interest, short time incremental DMD prediction can a the steering task that's runtime. You see, if you're if we're receiving a bunch of images and then doing a DMD or some run record correction, you can somehow predicted at runtime God is going to happen with your simulation and then take action using it You know, uses different capabilities built in, in your simulation coats. Again, I think that image metrics should complement our traditional error analysis. Look, we are using, you're using images right now. So you have to take a look on Image Metrics in the end, for compartmental PDE. S, we have seen that our theory and have been you know, in America experiments have shown that a couple DMD should be preferred. Yeah, that's the thing myself, and the sun reality our colleague, Amanda matassa. From he did from computer science, he helped She helped us a lot on the steering part like Patrick about the race, Alex viguerie, which now at cdc monographie, my former students as they come out, also my former students, during the course as my former students, Gabrielle bajos, who did a lot of works. In the end, he's finished his PhD right now. But a machine learning company in Brazil already hired the guy. And Victor Silva and Reynolds soza also helped us a lot. Victor Silva now is at Apple. And the Reynolds soza Is your colleague in Oak Ridge, you can talk to him about this steering stuff that he knows a lot about this. This is our, you know, I would like to acknowledge our supporters. And that's it. Thank you so much. Nice to be here with me today. And thanks for your attention. I'm ready for q&a. Yeah, thanks for that wonderful talk. Yeah, I'm particularly impressed by the comprehensive workflow on like, different simulations, different applications. And like the interesting error analysis, I read an analysis on the data compression. So let me see, I don't think we have a question in the chat room yet. So probably, I can kick off with one question. So I'm curious about like, what do you do? What I mean, what do you think about like incremental TMD? In the parametric case, like we have? I know, you do the Sacramento transport as an example, I think you have one particular workshop number and Smith number, right. So yeah. So if we have like, multiple of them, maybe we can do it in like simultaneously and rebuild the incremental SVD simultaneous Li. So do you think like, you will have giving a new testing parameters, another unseen problem in the in terms of the pressure, and there's some problem? So how would you like to the DMD prediction there? That's a very good question. You see, I think there is a strong potential. If you figure out the problem with this data visualizations, figure out, you know, this the script in order to produce the images, right? If you have a permit, and let's suppose that you do informatics exploration, and we have a lot of jobs running in a supercomputer. And for each one of them, you are downloading, you know, for the same point of view, more or less with same mesh, your download images, I can think I can think that you can do, you can show that there's a database of images and doing incremental DMD, we can show a new parameter and see if the reconstruction is okay. I think this is a test we're doing. worth doing. Because you're going to check out in runtime, what it what we're going to happen in this new parameter, and figure out if we have to start a new simulation. I mean, yes, not good. Is the indication for you. Okay, thanks. But more than that, let's, let's feel let's start simulation with the new premiers, right. Clear application of this idea? I see. Yeah, our group was more and more we were worried at that time, in order to complement what we have been doing in the steering in order to you know, in doing the streaming DMD to predict what's going to happen, and then intervene, intervene in the code. But what you have said is really I do agree with you, if you have if you figure out for, let's say, the same configuration and several parameters, and you have the images, you can just suppose you're streaming dem data, this new parameter and see if it's worthwhile to increase your parameter space or not. Yeah. Yeah, That's right, I think we can talk more on this merit. Because the lib rom team, we, we are also looking at like, having automatic like error indicators for like finding the parameters that we have to like build more snapshots for like having a better universal estimation in the whole parametric domain. So, yeah, maybe we'll learn from your experience. And maybe we can also talk about our work in the residuals riffin. Like sampling methods there. Yeah. Tell me that's, that's absolutely right. I mean, you could use for instance, KNN, or any other data to combine all these things, or near your neural network to you know, I mean, to do this, but as absolutely correct. I think your your team is, you need to do that. It's worth doing. Yeah. So I may ask one more question. So. So it is like, I don't have a clear idea about this. But you, I mean, in the hotel, we mainly record and talking about this simulations, but so I'm thinking about like, a data or decision making process or like multi Curie problems. So usually want to match the simulation with some kind of observed data. And there are some noise in there. So do you have like, any comments on some insights on how the noise level? Is? I mean, related or affecting the, like, the zfp compression level that you should choose in the DMD? That's a very good question. See, ya. Yeah, those things? Yeah. Big sign of the noise reason, is, is a measure of what the guys who wrote this, this paper I quoted here, were. Yeah, those guys, no, no, those guys here for the benchmark, they tested. And they, they, there is a, a, let's say, I mentioned, they, they propose a benchmark with all this compressor. And this, those guys, they are one of the apprentices that is new to our community, at least we don't tell much about this is this big sign noise ratio, and tells you how this noise generated by the compression effect. So your, your, your snapshots, in the end, when you decompress? How is that how your snapshots will be affected. So I mean, compressing and decompressing by something like, you know, 75 to add, or is, is considered good. This come from from from those image guys. You see, when we're doing this, we went to the image literature. If you take a look on the on the paper where we did that, we we quote, image book, this is something new for us ces sassy, guys, but it's bread and butter for for the image guys. So I'm saying that that's why I said in the end, there's more on data compression. And and that's why we choose zfp In the beginning, because there is this strong mathematical background and error analysis for zfp as well as for the other. Compressor is one. M guard Plus, there's a strong mathematical background in this M guard plus, so it's warm. I mean, it's hard to say at that point, which one is the best one. But again, I I I repeat what I wrote here, data flow compression here is here to stay. So is this something that our community has to start coping but in our experiments says just say to us that oh, okay, it's it's not that bad. We can cope with this because we can Wanna restart receiving data there? They're only available in in the compressor for Yeah, these are too big. Yeah, I totally agree like expressor is interesting. Like the zfp they are actively researched in within the cost of era now, and we'll probably certainly want to, like incorporate these techniques in the lib ROM that we are developing to, like, they are for instance, as Yfp is part of the HD F five, there's a plugin for this. And I'm pretty sure that your guys in the labs, don't just go for the exascale problem project guys and talk to them there. They will be readily available. Yes. Okay. Yeah, so let me ask once more, are there any more questions from the audience? So if there are no more questions, let's thank ever again for sharing his excellent research with us. Okay, you